>>> UP FIRST THE LENGTHS THE
TRUMP WORLD WENT TO TRY TO
INFLUENCE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE'S STAR WITNESS, THIS
IS ACCORDING TO THE WITNESS
HERSELF.
THE PANEL PUT OUT FRANCE SCRIPTS
OF FORMER WHITE HOUSE AIDE
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY.
THIS AS WE'RE EXPECTING THE
COMMITTEE TO RELEASE A FULL
REPORT OF ITS FINDINGS TODAY.
CNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES JOINS US
NOW.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: THIS IS, AS YOU
SAID, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON IN HER
OWN WORDS DESCRIBING WHAT SHE
SAYS WAS A PRESSURE CAMPAIGN
FROM TRUMP WORLD INCLUDING HER
TRUMP PAID ATTORNEY, STEFAN
PASSANTINO, TO REALLY DOWNPLAY
HER TESTIMONY, EVEN BEING
ENCOURAGED THAT IF SHE WAS LOYAL
SHE WOULD BE TAKEN CARE OF.
NOW, I DO WANT TO TELL YOU
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE SHE TALKS
ABOUT WHEN SHE HAD THIS BREAKING
POINT WITH HER ATTORNEY.
SHE SAYS THAT SHE WAS
COOPERATING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THEN HE TOLD HER NOT TO AND
SAID THIS, CONTEMPT IS A SMALL
RISK, BUT RUNNING TO THE RIGHT
IS BETTER FOR YOU.
NOW, A COUPLE THINGS TO NOTE
HERE.
THESE ARE TWO INTERVIEWS FROM
SEPTEMBER AFTER WE SAW THAT LIVE
INTERVIEW AND AFTER SHE HAD
MOVED ON FROM PASSANTINO.
THIS, AGAIN, IS WHY SHE SAID SHE
HAD THAT BREAKING POINT AND AS
YOU'LL REMEMBER ON MONDAY THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE ALLEGED
THEY HAD INFORMATION THAT A
WHITE HOUSE OR EXCUSE ME, A
TRUMP BACKED ATTORNEY HAD BEEN
PRESSURING THEIR CLIENT IN THIS
WAY TO SAY ESSENTIALLY
DOWNPLAYED THEIR TESTIMONY OR
MAYBE SAY THEY DON'T RECALL AND
CNN FOUND OUT THAT WAS FORMER
WHITE HOUSE LAWYER -- ETHICS
LAWYER, STEFAN PASSANTINO.
JUST TO GIVE YOU INSIGHT INTO
WHAT ELSE IS HERE THIS IS WHAT
SHE SAID HE TOLD HER TO SAY
SPECIFICALLY.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO YOU
STEFAN NEVER TOLD ME TO LIE.
HE SPECIFICALLY TOLD ME I DON'T
WANT YOU TO PERJURY YOURSELF BUT
"I DON'T RECALL" ISN'T PERJURY.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN AND
CAN'T RECALL.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HE SAID TO
HER ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
NOW, JUST TO GIVE YOU INSIGHT
INTO WHAT HER MIND WAS AT, SHE
SAYS THROUGH THIS PROCESS, SHE
WAS ALMOST AS THOUGH SHE FELT
LIKE SHE HAD TRUMP HIMSELF
LOOKING OVER HER SHOULDER,
BECAUSE SHE KNEW IN SOME FASHION
IT WOULD GET BACK TO HIM IF SHE
SAID ANYTHING THAT HE WOULD FIND
DISLOYAL AND THAT THAT PROSPECT
OF THAT GENUINELY SCARED ME.
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE SEEN THIS WORLD
RUIN PEOPLE'S LIVES OR TRY TO
RUIN THEIR CAREERS.
I HAD SEEN HOW VICIOUS THEY CAN
BE AND WANT TO READ A STATEMENT
FROM HER FORMER LAWYER, STEFAN
PASSANTINO.
THIS WAS IN RESPONSE TO THAT CNN
STORY SAYING THAT HE WAS THE
PERSON THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
ALLEGED HAD BEEN ASKING THEIR
CLIENT TO DOWNPLAY THEIR
TESTIMONY.
HE HAS NOT RESPONDED YET TO THE
ACTUAL TRANSCRIPTS.
SAYS, I BELIEVE MS. HUTCHINSON
WAS BEING TRUTHFUL AND
COOPERATIVE THROUGHOUT THE
SEVERAL INTERVIEW SESSIONS IN
WHICH I REPRESENTED HER.
PAMELA, THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
THING THAT IS IN HERE.
SHE ALSO TALKS ABOUT GETTING
JOBS DANGLED IN FRONT OF HER
SETTING UP MEETINGS AT THE TIME
SHE DIDN'T HAVE A JOB.
AGAIN, BEING TOLD BY PEOPLE IN
TRUMP'S ORBIT THAT SHE -- IF SHE
WAS LOYAL SHE WOULD BE TAKEN
CARE OF PARTICULARLY BEING
CALLED BY AIDES TO MARK MEADOWS
WHO SHE HAD WORKED FOR SAYING
MARK IS TELLING THAT AIDE TO
CALL HER AND SAY THAT SHE CAN
SAY SHE DOESN'T RECALL IF SHE
DOESN'T RECALL.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS SHE WAS
FEELING A PART OF THE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS HER OWN WORDS DESCRIBING
WHAT SHE FELT WAS THIS CAMPAIGN
DURING THIS TIME AND ONE OTHER
THING I DO WANT TO NOTE.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME QUESTION AS
TO HOW SHE ENDED UP WITH
PASSANTINO IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND DESCRIBED THAT AT LENGTH IN
THESE INTERVIEWS SAYING THAT SHE
HAD EXHAUSTED EVERY OTHER
OPTION, THAT SHE WAS LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE AND COULDN'T ACTUALLY
AFFORD A LAWYER THAT WAS -- THAT
SHE BELIEVED SHOULD BE
REPRESENTING HER AND THAT'S WHEN
SHE TURNED TO TRUMP WORLD FOR
HELP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WOW, THAT'S A LOT THERE, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS CNN'S
LAUREN FOX, POLITICO'S ALEX
BURNS, FRANCESCA CHAMBERS AND
CNN LEGAL ANALYST ELLIOT
WILLIAMS.
WOW, REMARKABLE.
THIS IS UNDER OATH FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S STAR WITNESS,
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, HER FIFTH
INTERVIEW WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
LAYS OUT THIS PICTURE, ALEX, OF
A PRESSURE CAMPAIGN COMING AT
HER FROM ALL ENDS OF THE TRUMP
WORLD THAT SHE FELT INDEBTED TO
THEM AND WAS REPEATEDLY TOLD TO
BE LOYAL, THAT THERE COULD BE
JOBS FOR HER, AND THEN, OF
COURSE, WE KNOW SHE LEFT AND
SWITCHED LAWYERS.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT WHAT
STANDS OUT TO ME, FIRST OF ALL,
WE HAD HEARD SOME OF THESE
ELEMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE IN A
PRETTY VAGUE FASHION, RIGHT,
THAT WITNESSES FELT INTIMIDATED
OR DETERRED FROM SPEAKING IN ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
WHAT REALLY SORT OF POPS OUT TO
ME JUST AS A POLITICAL REPORTER
IS THAT WE'VE KNOWN FOR THE
LONGEST TIME THAT THIS IS HOW
TRUMP'S WORLD OPERATE, NOT
NECESSARILY WITH WITNESSES WHO
ARE TESTIFYING UNDER OATH BUT
JUST PRETTY COMPREHENSIVELY IF
YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
RUNNING SOMEWHERE AND YOU WANT
HIS SUPPORT YOU NEED TO BEND THE
KNEE IN SOME WAY.
IF YOU'RE A GOVERNOR LOOKING FOR
VENTILATORS FOR YOUR STATE OR
DISASTER AID OF SOME KIND, YOU
NEED TO MAKE A SHOW OF LOYALTY,
SO I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT TERRIBLY SHOCKING
THAT THIS IS HOW LAWYERS CLOSE
TO DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE
INTERACTING WITH JUST PEOPLE
GENERALLY, BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
RISKS AND CONSEQUENCES OF
BEHAVING LIKE THIS ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK YOU DO GET COMING OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE A PICTURE OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM AS NOT
NECESSARILY HAVING ADAPTED TO A
WORLD WHERE THERE ARE REAL
CONSEQUENCES WHERE THEY DON'T
CONTROL THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OR MECHANICS OF INVESTIGATIONS.
>> SOME READS OUT OF LIKE A
MAFIA NOVEL.
OH, MY GOSH, WHEN I WAS READING
IT AND SHOULD NOTE AGAIN, THIS
IS CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SPEAKING
UNDER OATH TO THE COMMITTEE.
STEFAN PASSANTINO HAS RELEASED A
STATEMENT, HE SAYS I BELIEVED
MISS HUTCHINSON WAS BEING TRUTH
KNULL AND COOPERATIVE WITH THE
COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT THE SEVERAL
INTERVIEW SESSIONS IN WHICH I
REPRESENTED HER SO CLEARLY HE
HAS ANOTHER SIDE TO THIS, BUT IN
THE TRANSCRIPT, ELLIOT, IT SAYS
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE OKAY.
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF YOU.
THIS IS WHAT HUTCHINSON
DESCRIBED PASSANTINO AS SAYING,
QUOTE, JUST DOWNPLAY YOUR
POSITION.
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT MARK MEADOWS,
HER FORMER BOSS, CHIEF OF STAFF
TO TRUMP, PUT YOU IN THIS
POSITION.
WE JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON
PROTECTING THE PRESIDENT.
WE ALL KNOW YOU'RE LOYAL.
LET'S JUST GET YOU IN AND OUT
AND THIS DAY WILL BE EASY, I
PROMISE.
>> OH, LORD.
WHERE TO BEGIN?
FIRST YEAR OF CRIMINAL LAW CLASS
PLAYING OUT BECAUSE OF ALL THE
SORT OF ISSUES THIS RAISED.
NUMBER ONE, WHAT YOU HAVE IS
KNOWLEDGE ON THE PART OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT THAT HE LOST
THE ELECTION.
THAT IS RELEVANT TO AN
OBSTRUCTION CHARGE AND
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES CHARGE AND RELEVANT TO
THIS FALSE STATEMENT CHARGE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT THAT HE KNEW HE
LOST, RIGHT?
WHAT YOU'LL SEE FROM THE
COMMITTEE, I THINK IS ROLLING
OUT ALL THESE STATEMENTS WHERE
PEOPLE BROUGHT TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT THAT HE LOST, TWO,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTING A
WITNESS TO SAY SOMETHING OR NOT
SAY SOMETHING ON THE STAND IN
THE GOAL OF FRUSTRATING THE
INVESTIGATION IS AN ACT OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
IT'S NOT JUST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HERE BUT PASSANTINO
AND OTHERS AROUND HIM WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO INK
INFLUENCE HER TESTIMONY.
SO THIS IS QUITE SERIOUS AND
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE
STATEMENTS ARE WHAT YOU CALL
HEARSAY, IT'S ONE PERSON SAYING
WHAT ANOTHER PERSON SAYS,
THEY'RE PILING THEM UP BECAUSE
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CORROBORATE THEM.
>> ON THAT NOTE THERE HAS
BEEN -- WE HAVE SEEN
CORROBORATION OF TRUMP KNOWING
HE LOST AND TRYING TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION AND SAYS IN THE
TRANSCRIPTS SEVERAL TIMES DONALD
TRUMP WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT TOLD
HER, I KNOW I LOST BUT WE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY OUT OF THIS AND
THAT IS PRETTY DAMNING BECAUSE
STATE OF MIND INSTEAD IS PART OF
WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT.
>> MARK MEADOWS TOLD CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON ACCORDING TO THE
TRANSCRIPTS HE ALSO BELIEVED
THAT THE PRESIDENT KNEW HE HAD
LOST AND THAT IS SIGNIFICANT
HERE FOR WHAT DOJ IS LOOKING AT.
WE KNOW THAT DOJ HAS STARTED
GETTING SOME OF THE INFORMATION
FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
IT'S GOING TO BE OBVIOUSLY UP TO
THEM WHAT THEY WANT TO DO HERE.
THE REFERRALS DO NOT REQUIRE
THEM TO TAKE ANY ACTION, BUT I
THINK THAT THE LARGE THING THAT
STUCK OUT TO ME WAS PEOPLE
FORGET THAT THESE ARE GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES.
THESE ARE NOT WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON --
>> SHE'S ONLY 6 YEARS OLD.
>> SHE IS DEALING WITH THE FACT
SHE WILL HAVE TO GO BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND TELLING HER MOM
THAT SHE FELT LIKE WHAT AM I
GOING TO DO?
I CAN'T AFFORD A FANCY LAWYER
THAT I THINK I PROBABLY NEED TO
GET ME THROUGH THIS SO SHE HAD
TO TURN TO TRUMP WORLD FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME IN HER OWN WORDS
AND I THINK THAT IS SUCH A
COMPELLING PART OF THIS
TRANSCRIPT AND SOMETHING PEOPLE
BACK HOME I THINK NEED TO
REMEMBER ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
WORK --
>> I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
HER AGE IS IMPORTANT.
THE PRESSURE SHE WAS UNDER.
I MEAN SHE SAID MANY TIMES IN
THE TRANSCRIPT SHE WAS RELAYING
TO THE COMMITTEE HOW SCARED SHE
WAS.
SHE WAS WORRIED THAT IF SHE
TURNED ON THE PRESIDENT THAT
TRUMP WORLD WOULD TURN ON HER
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT A
26-YEAR-OLD WOULD BE FEELING.
I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOUR TAKE IS ON
WHAT SHE ALSO SAID THAT
PASSANTINO ALLEGEDLY TOLD HER,
CONTEMPT IS A SMALL RISK BUT
RUNNING TO THE RIGHT IS BETTER
FOR YOU.
>> WELL, AS YOU WERE SAYING, I
THINK THE POINT OF THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS POINT IS TO KEEP THIS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF PEOPLE'S MINDS,
BECAUSE FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, PLANNING TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN, A LOT OF THIS
IS GOING TO PLAY OUT
POLITICALLY, PLAY OUT ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
TESTIMONY, THOUGH, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HOPE HICKS FOR A
MOMENT.
SHE WAS SOMEONE WHO WAS SO CLOSE
TO THE PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT
SAW HER AS LIKE A DAUGHTER AND
SHE WAS ALSO ON THE RECORD
SAYING THAT SHE TOLD PEOPLE THAT
HE HAD ESSENTIALLY LOST, TRIED
TO GET HIM TO SPEAK OUT ON
JANUARY 6th AND THAT IS SO
CRITICAL.
SHE IS SOMEONE WHO WHEN SHE LEFT
THE FIRST TIME HE DID A WHOLE
COLONNADE WALK WITH HER WHICH IS
USUALLY RESERVED FOR FOREIGN
LEADERS SO HER TESTIMONY IS VERY
IMPORTANT ALSO.
>> WRAPPING UP WITH YOU, ELLIOT,
WHAT IS LEGALLY LOOKING AT THE
CONTEMPT CLAIM THAT SHE MADE
THAT SHE FELT PRESSURED FROM
TRUMP ALLIES ON THIS, NOT TO
TALK, IN JUNE, WE SHOULD NOTE,
AND INSTEAD RISK CONTEMPT AND
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE WITH THE
LAWYER SAYING, HEY, DON'T OFFER
TOO MUCH UNLESS THEY ASK YOU.
>> IT STEPS UP TO THE LINE AND
PROBABLY MIGHT BE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, YOU'RE TELLING SOMEONE
TO RUN AFOUL OF A COMMITTEE THAT
IS INVESTIGATING THEM.
YOU'RE TELLING THEM NOT TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS TRUTHFULLY AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO STRAIN REALLY
HARD SAYING YOU'RE TRYING TO
FRUSTRATE OR IMPEDE THE
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S A FEDERAL CRIME.
>> SOMETHING DOJ IN THE END IS
INVESTIGATING SO WE WILL SEE.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH.